thousands of Palestinians nearly half of
them women and children have been killed
and injured after a week of Israeli
strikes on Gaza according to officials
in The
Enclave the attacks are Israel's
response to the assault by Hamas
militants which killed over 1,400
Israelis on October 7th many of them
women and
children
on Friday Israel demanded people in Gaza
City to evacuate to the southern part of
The Enclave prompting fears of a
humanitarian
disaster but as the Israeli forces turn
parts of Gaza into Rubble the question
is can Palestinian civilians actually
hide anywhere from the
strikes the Gaza Strip is a sliver of
land and bordering Israel and Egypt
twice the size of Washington DC with
more than 2 million people living there
it is one of the most densely populated
places on
Earth over the past week nearly half of
the strip's population have fled their
homes according to the United
Nations people have sought shelter in un
run schools hospitals and local hotels
many of which have been hit by Israeli
bombing according to the UN but hardly
anyone could flee The
Enclave that is because Gaza has been
under blockade from both Israel and
Egypt since 2007 when Hamas seized
control of the area making it difficult
to leave Gaza even before the war a
heavily fortified perimeter called The
Iron Wall separates Gaza and Israel
normally some people could cross the
border at this Crossing but not since
the Hamas militants raided it the border
between Egypt and Gaza is also fortified
with only one point to get through at
thefa Crossing but Palestinians can't
pass it without a special
permit and Israeli forces have bombed
The Crossing several times in recent
days making it even more difficult to
cross for those who have permission
according to local authorities Egyptian
officials and the
UN with Israel's military having ordered
a total Siege on Gaza supplies of food
and fuel are no longer reaching The
Enclave getting Aid via Egypt is also
Complicated by the bombing of the Rafa
Crossing on Tuesday trucks purportedly
carrying aid from Egypt were forced to
move back to the Egyptian side of the
Border as densely populated areas of
Gaza get relentless LLY bombarded
hospitals are struggling with the number
of
injured with power running out in the
strip the hospitals are at risk of
turning into Mass morgs according to the
international Committee of the Red Cross
the Israeli military said that it has a
reduced Capac capacity for precision
strikes because its forces are stretched
thin military officials haven't
explained why it attacked the Rafa
border
crossing after the Israeli Army ordered
Gins to evacuate to the southern part of
The Enclave accusing Hamas of using
civilians as human Shields Hamas told
civilians to stay in their homes but
even as people go south the UN warns
that such mass movement will lead to
devastating humanitarian consequences
now